a bad trip so any bad trip that I've
ever had has actually been a positive
experience because it's forced me to
confront feelings that I've suppressed
so it's hard in the moment and I've
white knuckled my way through it but
I've also faced some of my greatest life
trauma and greatest fear and stuff head
on and I think it's made me a better
person you have to wow that's heavy so
so that's what you're taught when you do
it a lot like don't run from things run
towards them like if you're having a bad
trip you got to go head on to the thing
and go like like I'm not afraid of you
anymore and all right you hear me I'm
not afraid of you
anymore that
[__] so